when it comes up national lead officer
for unite hi it's good to see you thanks
for joining us on the program I had its
second reading yesterday the government
moving on with it yes it's uh
predictable unfortunately
um but look this uh legislation it's
unworkable
it's undemocratic and it's unnecessary
and I think the last point is probably
the most important it's unnecessary
because if you take the NHS for example
we've been prepared to sit down and
negotiate
minimum Staffing levels whenever there's
been strike action now with this
legislation instead of that negotiation
being with clinical Medical Specialists
that would be potentially with the
Secretary of State Stephen Barclay
deciding uh what's uh safe in a hospital
I'd rather rely on a medical clinician
so it's completely unnecessary look it
also fails to deal with the cost of
living crisis it fails to deal with the
crisis in the NHS and um
we have an ocean of crocodile tears from
conservative ministers saying this is
about patient safety uh it's not if they
really cared about patient safety they
wouldn't be talking about minimum
Staffing levels during strike action
they'd be talking about safe Staffing
levels every single day of the year so
how is it unworkable and how is it
undemocratic it's undemocratic because
we can go through a legal process at the
moment where people can vote to take
strike action exercising a democratic
mandate so please count
please come no no no the police can't
and my personal view is that the police
should have that right but that's so yes
to be able to go on strike I think the
police should have the right to be able
to be balloted to take strike action I
think I treat them as workers uh just
like any other uh worker what do you
think might happen if the police went on
strike well that's for the that's for
the police to discuss we don't represent
police officers so it's undemocratic
because people take part in a ballot and
have the right to be able to take strike
action it's unworkable because if you
actually look at the detail of the
legislation there's in fact very little
detail in there who decides who's going
to be able to take strike action and
who's not going to take strike action in
the workplace who decides what
proportion it's going to be who decides
which individuals are going to be told
you can't take strike action and in none
of that detail is actually in the
legislation so as it stands it's
actually unworkable do not think the
patients let's let's say NHS workers
we if we don't have a minimum level
patients lives are at risk I completely
agree with you okay I think they should
be safe Staffing levels in the NHS every
single day of the year now the irony
here is that during the Industrial
action in the NHS we were negotiating
minimum Staffing levels in some cases
were better than on non-striking days so
I would support my union would support a
debate around safe Staffing levels in
the NHS every single day you know only
25 percent of shifts have the planned
numbers of staff on them
founded then by NHS workers going on
strike well no because we negotiate
minimum levels emergency cover when
there is a strike action and also our
members in the NHS have made clear that
this dispute is not just about pay pays
inextricably linked to Staffing
Recruitment and Retention safety and
therefore the service in the NHS okay
let me ask you about the amendment that
the Lords have put forward they had I
think several amendments one of them
um if accepted would mean that
um
allowing strikes to happen without
workers uh being sacked you've accepted
would that not provide protection for
workers it would certainly uh make the
bill uh better but the reality is that
we have a raft of anti-trade Union
legislation that is in uh at the moment
we have hurdles that we have to jump
over this is going to be just another
hurdle and we'll jump over this one as
well but it's simply not necessary and
it doesn't deal with the fundamental
problems it doesn't deal with the cost
of living crisis Mick Lynch um we all
know who Mick Lynch's says there'll be a
mass campaign of workplace Disobedience
if that goes through would you would you
encourage your members to join in that
well we'll look at creative ways to get
around the legislation so for instance
specifically he said workplace Mass
campaign of workplace disobedience is
that something that you would want your
members to join in well we'll look at
ways of getting around the legislation
for instance such as action short of
strike action which actually could end
up prolonging disputes and disputes
taking longer but on on mixed comments
I'm not surprised that when people's
legitimate legal rights are under hack
I'm not surprised if people then turn
around and say well we're not going to
play by the rules okay but they wouldn't
be legal would there be illegal if the
law was brought in
so what would be illegal the rights that
workers enjoy at the moment they they
would be illegal well thankfully we can
still take uh strike action
um but as I said we will look at
creative ways of getting around this
legislation now that could include
action short of strikes now the irony
there is that that actually ends up
prolonging a dispute our Union has been
involved in some 600 disputes over the
last 15 months winning 80 percent of
those and I'm glad to say
the vast majority have been settled
without strike action having to take
place so it's an unnecessary piece of
legislation it's good to see you thanks
very much David thank you